E
BORDER, NEIL.
>> Neil: SO TRUE.
THANKS, JONATHAN.
BRANDON JUDD, THE BORDER PATROL
UNION PRESIDENT.
BRANDON, IF THEIR JOB IS NOT
DIFFICULT ENOUGH, THEY RISK
GETTING COVID THESE DAYS WHETHER
YOU'RE VACCINATED OR NOT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE NEW
DEVELOPMENT?
>> I LIKE TO TAKE A STEP BACK
AND ADDRESS WHAT SECRETARY
MAYORKAS SAID.
HE SAID THIS IS A COMPLICATED I.
YOU.
IN REALITY, IT'S NOT
COMPLICATED, THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT CAN BE FIXED QUICKLY.
IT'S BEEN FIXED TIME AND TIME
AGAIN.
THIS ADMINISTRATION REFUSES TO
IMPLEMENT THE POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM.
AS LONG AS WE CONTINUE TO
RELEASE PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES, REWARD PEOPLE FOR
VIOLATING LAWS, WE'LL CONTINUE
TO SEE THE NUMBERS GO UP.
IN MY WILDEST DREAMS I NEVER
THOUGHT THAT AN ADMINISTRATION
WOULD HAVE ALLOWED THE BORDER TO
GET TO THE POINT THAT WE'RE AT
NOW.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THERE'S A
CAP.
EVEN IF WE GO TO 300,000
APPREHENSIONS, DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THIS ADMINISTRATION WILL ADDRESS
THE ISSUE.
SO WE CAN EXPECT TO CONTINUE TO
SEE COVID ENTER THE UNITED
STATES BY ILLEGAL MEANS.
IT'S SCARY FOR THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
>> Neil: WHAT IS INTERESTING, I
KNOW THEY SET UP AN ENCLOSED
FACILITY THAT WOULD HANDLE THESE
CASES.
THAT IS ALREADY TOO LIMITED FOR
THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT THEY
HAVE.
I'M WONDERING WITH THE SURGE
CONTINUING, THE MIGRANTS
CONTINUING TOWARD THE BORDER,
HOW CAN AGENTS JUST KEEP UP WITH
THIS?
IT'S ONE THING TO SORT IT OUT
AND ADJUDICATE THE CASES, HANDLE
WHAT YOU CAN, SEPARATELY DEAL
WITH THOSE OR CONTRACTING THE
VIRUS.
BUT IT'S ALSO YOU KNOW, MOVING
PIECES ON A CHESS BOARD.
YOU CAN'T KEEP UP WITH IT.
>> WE'RE NOT KEEPING UP WITH IT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
AGENTS IN THE FIELD, YOU LOOK AT
THE NUMBER OF GOT-AWAYS, WE'RE
NOT KEEPING UP WITH ANYTHING
HAPPENING ON THE BOARDER.
THAT MEANS THERE'S DANGEROUS
PRODUCTS COMING ACROSS, THE
DRUGS ARE COMING ACROSS, KILLING
OUR CHILDREN AND RURAL AREAS,
SUBURBS, IN OUR INNER CITIES.
ALL OF THIS IS HAPPENING ON THE
BORDER AND IT'S ALL BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT IMPLEMENTING THOSE
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
BE EFFECTIVE TO SECURE THE
BORDER, AGAIN, WE'VE DISCUSSED
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN, NEIL.
THIS IS AN EASY SOLUTION.
IT MATTERS WHETHER OR NOT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO PUSH
BACK AGAINST THEIR BASE.
RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT DOING IT.
>> Neil: APPARENTLY IT GOT TENSE
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN?
WHAT DID YOU FIND OUT?
I KNOW YOU WEREN'T PHYSICALLY
THERE.
I WOULDN'T SAY NASTY BUT BACK TO
MY ORIGINAL TERMS, TENSE.
>> IT DID GET INTENSE.
HE VISITED WITH AGENTS AT
McALLEN AT THE 6:00 A.M. MUSTER.
I GOT BRIEFS ON THAT.
IT WAS VERY INTENSE.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS WERE
VERY UPSET WITH SECRETARY
MAYORKAS.
THEY WERE UPSET WITH THE CHIEF.
ONE AGENT SAID HOW WOULD YOU
RATE YOUR SUCCESS?
HE TAP DANCED AROUND THAT
QUESTION.
HIS SUCKS  -- SUCCESS HAS NOT
BEEN GOOD.
I KNOW SECRETARY MAYORKAS.
I KNOW HE KNOWS WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
HE'S GIVING THE ADMINISTRATION
THE ADVICE.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
LISTENING TO THE SECRETARY.
SO HE HAS TO BE THE FACE THAT
GOES OUT THERE AND HE HAS TO
TAKE THE BRUNT OF THE HAVE IT -